you ready for this yes yeah are you
ready come and get it no no no no so we
are having just a little late-night
trips it's Heuser us before they close
Oh where's my keys in your purse there
you sighted or what I'm so excited I'm
tweeting about it the new LEGO
Minifigures serious their team is out I
can't find them anywhere but I looked
online and I saw that Toys R Us had them
in stock there we are no other Toys R Us
is in the area had them and my normal
usual spot puzzles ooh did not have them
either
they close at nine oh so we've got an
hour
listen up any longer than 10 minutes
here excuse me
looks like something I'd like to golf in
okay Lego yellow what's up it looks like
only like like a Lego holy boy who's 20
inches tall I'm gonna need this because
I got to sit down when I do my my thing
you do not need that put that back I'm
gonna put it back put back right now you
can sit on the ground there's no one
here oh no one's turning up on a
Thursday the Wednesday what day is it I
think it's Wednesday where's your butts
you brick storage it isn't that it no
but maybe they ran out I told her not to
take the chair listen do you want to ask
for help right here right ow oh my god I
got injured huh
I injured myself
I've never been not here hmm
oh I deleted something on my phone I bet
this is this foreleg horn that's the
board
all right I want to go by these six see
what they are and then I'm going to
continue to feel for the rest thought
you know just we just got to see if
we're on the right track you know like
maybe like a piece of paper there is
paper in here what do we think it is
whatever is the disco diva yeah just go
disco diva check me scaling just
crossing local lady Cyclops oh boy
Cyclops unicorn right we're getting
we're getting somewhere
yeah you don't have this guy evil wizard
he's in there he's a knight Knight
number 10 this is great we're getting
some water paleontologists Oh get that
blown the bone the let her cross her off
she's got the bone okay okay mmm look
this we just walk you think oh yeah okay
can you believe so we were just in there
you don't feel it up the bags and this
woman comes by and she's looking for the
hot dog which Jenna that only thing the
only one I good and then she helped just
find the rest of the one who you're
missing and now I'm gonna go home and
put these together I might actually need
your help if there's there's a whole
mess of mess in this bag
okay dollars the veneer that's the real
question
should be driven for their there was
let's drive because I think it might be
further away than we think it might be
turnout at Panera and I'm gonna do a
little a little putting together before
we get our baby she's missing there are
pieces everywhere oh really
my favorite